I don't love the phrase when people call
what we're doing just co-parenting it's
not like you drop them me I drop them to
you
okay swallows don't speak to me yeah
we're very much on the same everything
yeah how did you get to this place
review and Courtney and Sophie and the
kids I saw you say on Instagram your
kids your priority how do you get to
this good place together I think you
just gotta figure out really what's
important to you at the end of the day I
mean there's so many different things
that can pull you in different
directions and you could look online and
Instagram social meaning all these
things but at the end of the day I mean
you just want to be happy you want to be
content you want to be comfortable you
want to love your people another level
Scott it's like oh I know what goes on
there vacation with like it's like this
exes together thing is amazing I'm super
soft so impressed by it how do you do it
I think the real part is life is a
challenge and if you work at what you
want you can get it but it takes hard
work simple as that
you can easily live less of a life
without working as hard and that's a
beauty minutes hard work for all parties
I think 400 port Sofia they're all
really it's I'm really proud of all of
them yeah I got it I mean QWERTY being
your older sister do you guys do you
look to them and kind of learn from what
you know Kourtney and Scott are doing
yeah no I think they're doing amazing
and I think everyone has to handle their
co-parenting situation in their own
style but my mom and my dad were like
that it took them years but my dad would
come over once a week for family dinners
and would play golf with my stepdad and
so we come from a family where we
believe in that and you share children
with people and that's how it should be
and love is love and I'm so proud of
them and I'm so proud of them promoting
that and hopefully you know inspiring
other people that it's a beautiful thing
to get along with each other and for
your kids to see that you know I'm not
your typical house flipper
oh my gosh well we see Courtney tell you
she's proud of you on the show yeah how
does that feel for you to hear yeah
that's great I mean I think we've been
through so much and so many things and
to hear her be proud of me means you
know a ton to me you guys are like the
co-parenting gold-standard I say they
are thank God we have what we have
because our kids aren't affected by our
problems